everybody's so
you can feel how kind every everybody's
so nice and ready to applaud and be look
everybody's going like this you can't
uh you have an incredible crowd well
they're just so excited to see you
because sonic 2 had the biggest box
office opening ever for a video game
tournament
wow i used to play it i used to play
sega were you a big sega fan i was so i
had a super nintendo and david fernandez
because you never could have both no
david fernandez had a genesis so i'd
play at his house
uh sonic and then in my house it'd be
super nintendo now fast forward and
you're in the movie it's crazy did you
feel that pressure
should i be here in a swivel yeah that's
good yeah that's why it is a swivel i
don't want to be rude and over the
shoulder
although i'm so striking over there like
ask me a quick question
ben how are you today very good thank
you
i think i should leave my head and then
follow like that's what i'll do i'll
lead with my head and then follow i'm
not trying to be rude to anybody but yes
the opening weekend is
very exciting and also
so i've never been in a movie of this
stature before and they give you all
these numbers another number they said
is it's jim carrey's biggest domestic
opening weekend ever which is crazy
because he's like the king and there you
are
with him
yeah um well i
have letters because the last time you
were on we talked about i do a segment
here on this show called dear drew which
we do a zip code of the day
and sometimes in this modern world i
want to drop a technological mic and you
know beam people in star trek style but
i also want to harken back to like the
gentleness of you know the television
that we all grew up on and
i love snail mail and
you came on and we discovered this about
each other and became pen pals yeah i
have typewriters i love
i love using the reason i love
typewriters is you can use them the same
exact way you use them like 70 years ago
i'm using the same exact device that
someone did 70 years ago and i love
writing people letters and i believe
drew it was you who got a letter from
e.t and look i got an alf and he sent an
alpha playing card from the 90s as well
i'm not going i'm not getting spent on
it look at like how cool this is i'm
sorry but like
this is not a text but i will say this
because you're obviously you're very
busy both you're very busy i wasn't
expecting a letter back drew wrote me
back a five-page handwritten letter uh
back and it was amazing and like went
into detail and put your heart into it
and then like played with the bit that
you're responding to e.t but yeah also
as a as a human being talking to a human
being yes uh yes but there's e.t was
very he was on one one day this was this
was him he was a little naughty this is
so cute i remember you guys saying
you're going to write each other and you
actually follow through again i know
what are the odds of people following
through i don't know but is it time for
another letter it could be continue our
pen paling i have a feeling e.t has a
lot more to say to drew barrymore well
gertie's around
[Music]
you